the commentaries for star wars visions
visions visions i'm here with lon and
danielle and we are going to go through
all nine visions that we had as part of
a group masculine experience but it
turned out that star wars adapted them
into uh into anime that's fun yeah we'll
show you some deleted scenes if we have
any not sure if we do actually this week
uh we'll respond to questions and
comments from viewers like yourselves
keep those coming in the chat a little
tease you with next week's honest
trailer which we are actually debating
just before
we started shooting i think we should
tease them with both options like we're
debating this clue versus or that clue
yeah i'll need help coming up with a
clue so you can all right i'll have that
on the back burner um and then we can we
can just touch briefly on star wars
visions because what is there to say
besides like it's nine different
japanese approaches to star wars and
some of them are pretty neat and some of
them aren't as neat uh
what do you guys think about the whole
experience
i mostly liked it like it was i don't
know i always find
anytime you can give me star wars that's
not like full of skywalkers i'm super
psyched about it because i always want
to like get to see what the rest of the
universe might look like it's still
incredibly jedi heavy but it's also like
look if i got to ride a star wars i'm
putting in some jedi like of course you
are they're jedi it's fun they're
magical space wizards but uh
for the most part like i mean here's the
thing what's great about it is that like
if you don't like one it's over in like
15 minutes and then you might like the
next one um so yeah for the most part i
mean and even then the ones that i was
like met about it was just met it wasn't
any was like if this this is the worst
thing i've ever seen um they're either
like a five on a scale to ten or they're
like a nine on a scale to ten i feel
like that's doing really good for an
anthology
yeah working five to nine it's good i
would go so far
they're they're mostly good like
it's a better average than i sort of
would have expected going in where i
figure i'd like some and not like the
others like i think for the most part
it's funny though uh i i it's totally
subjective like i don't think one is
objectively the best and another is
objectively not as well done it very
much relies on like what kind of
animation styles do you like what kind
of aspects of the star wars universe or
characters are you most into are you a
baby or are you right so like foreign
the the one the the tatooine rhapsody
we're we're a band and we're playing for
both like i know a lot of people it's
like their favorite one like that one
didn't play for me at all it felt like
the yeah i like the concept but kids as
soon as the uh as soon as the music
starts yeah i just like i wasn't that
into like joseph gordon-levitt
serenading me with paramore songs
i was like shouldn't there be ladies
you're saying a lot of words i like um
black people love paramore no one knows
why yeah that's weird
black people
and it's like and and i don't know and i
find jose gordon well i still find him
delightful um tatooine rhapsody was
easily my favorite one right i think
it's just because it's so weird that's
the bottom of my list oh man i think
it's just so weird i feel like but i
don't i don't think it's it's
objectively bad i just think it was that
was was not my taste and like my
favorites were you know obviously not
like i thought the ninth jedi was
awesome and that's not some other
people's taste so you know i i i think
that overall it was a really well done
uh series and they're all there's things
to recommend about every one of them
even the ones that weren't my personal
fans all right well we know that's what
you guys are here for let's say nice
things about star wars uh roll roll them
visions and we always pause after uh
each one
[Music]
so they put a little star wars on the
star wars hub so you can watch star wars
before the next star wars comes out
comes what any responsible content
factory would do and outsources the job
to asia in these non-canon japanese
short films that would all make for a
better movie trilogy than the one we
just got somehow palpatine returned
and yeah
especially the furry episode here are
all nine animated shorts from star wars
visions well pause i mean look it's easy
it's easier to make a compelling 15
minutes uh then it is uh i don't know
the eight hours total of cinema but i
i guess i'd just be excited to get away
from the skywalker saga which probably
wouldn't be the next film trilogy
anyways but i stand by that it's a
little hyperbolic but i think that the
grounds are there for more interesting
stories in pretty much every single one
of these than um
than what we got
agree disagree very few things have ever
been made better by being longer
true
it's just like you think about i don't
know you think about like a good sketch
that you like and you're like do i want
it to be like a tight three to five
minutes or do i want it to go on for two
hours sometimes there's things that i'm
really liking and like i will parse out
episodes or pages of a book or something
because i don't want it to end um
but yeah generally you want to start the
story as late as possible and end it as
early as possible like in the events
that you're describing
yeah i mean i think that one thing that
the the movies always get kind of hung
up on or or or have to do depending on
your opinion is like recreating these
scenarios and mirroring that original
movie in that original trilogy kind of
over and over again like force awakens
is sort of a reboot of new hope and
they're always like oh is the second one
gonna be this trilogy's empire and when
you're doing stuff like visions you just
the freedom from that like you can
reference and bring in this character or
that one
but it doesn't feel like this has to
feel like return of the jedi and movies
sometimes even the rogue ones and the
solos kind of fall into that of like
well this should feel like
this dynamic from this movie or this
scene from this movie and there is that
here i mean the very first short in this
collection there's like i see where
they're having a lightsaber battle on a
log as it goes down a river approaching
a waterfall and it's very star wars the
old reverse uh mustafar whatever yeah
right it's like a super star warsy but
like you could you pick and choose your
moments as opposed to having it feel
like well this movie has to be basically
a two-hour homage to this movie yeah
yeah it almost makes you wonder what
star wars would be like if it wasn't a
uh
carefully crafted uh uh meticulously
managed ip and like you know any anyone
could come along and tell a story in
this world right yeah it's like all
these franchises have to be two things
they're this setting and platform for
storytelling but then they're also like
a brand and you have to have your like
brand identity and like keep you know
like it has to feel consistent in that
way and so it's like always a bounce
like can we do like star wars like we
just make a generic like x-brand star
wars like tolkien like people tell
stories with forks and elves and dwarves
and stuff like that and his estate isn't
uh suing every high fantasy novel out of
existence like we just call them
uh uh
deja and piss lots of space fantasy and
you could write a star warsian space
fantasy and just make up new names and
you'd legally be okay yeah all right
just read fan fiction just read the
fanfiction oh yeah just very good there
you go nice all right keep playing
from the studio that's probably going to
make optimus prime a shogun next comes a
general grievous level circle jerk of
influences in this kurosawa influence
star wars influenced by the star wars
most influenced by kurosawa again it's
like poetry so if they rhyme where a
rodent battles lucy lou for the fate of
a small feudal village but only after
his droid gets hurt he couldn't give a
[ __ ] before that
how dare you bedroid was wearing a hat
ronin holiday
you know yeah pause um
i don't have much to say that one was
really cool
it was the animation on this one oh my
god like that charcoaly style was so
good yeah it was such a great way to
start this off um kudos it turns out the
people that make movies can sometimes be
and make things are really good at
picking out stuff um yeah this was one
of my favorites like i really liked it
also joined with a hat
also have you guys seen that jangy moo
uh
chinese movie shadow
no it's like one of those big lucha like
crouching tiger like epic martial arts
thing but there's a whole battle scene
where a bunch of guys have these like
umbrella weapons where they're like
spinning them around and so it can
deflect things but they can also like
throw daggers using them and like hit
you with them and whatever and it
obviously that move like there's no way
the people who made this we're not
thinking of that with the umbrella
lightsaber it's such a cool way to
repurpose that idea and that weapon in a
new way that feels star wars-y but also
like nothing else you've seen in star
wars exactly and
that it was awesome
normally yeah
just like normally i don't like like the
the too many lightsabers kind of a thing
um like i think i think like you know
like general grievous
um well there's just like a lot of like
i don't know i i i just diminishing
returns like just dude
yeah it's like the same thing with
wrestling i just like two dudes fighting
it out um but this umbrella like i
really dug it i thought it was great
yeah
i also like that the jedi that leaves it
to the guy like who helped him in the
town like there you go there's like
what's he gonna do with it it's like
some
it's like an extension
it's like you're leaving him a
lightsaber accessory fresh wheat
seems useless
it take me it took me back to uh
original trilogy vibes where um they
will allude to stuff and characters will
will drop hints or there will be
mysteries that aren't immediately
explained by you know two people sitting
in a room and talking out or a
presentation or or a piece of or a lore
book or something like that that said
there is a there is a novel
a novelization of this short um that's
out now or or out soon to tell you oh
why would a student fight other sith oh
here's everything you need to know but i
liked the mystery i feel like that's
something that's that's uh missing from
um from everything new in star wars or
the mandalorian kind of has it but the
answer's usually luke skywalker all
right uh let's keep going number two
in a world where the most popular music
on the planet is called jizz every
excuse for the only show
less appealing mid-2000s pop punk in
this extremely straightforward story
about a band that gets broken up by
chibi boba fett and immediately reunites
because any more story would take time
away from joseph gordon-levitt singing
see this is what happens when an anime
doesn't get eight minutes of opening
credits they just drop it into the
episode
blink 2187
yeah i just it's the it's it was the
song like if you're gonna build so much
around like uh uh like tenacious d
though the greatest song in the world or
whatever like you better deliver i don't
think
i'm just not fine that pop punk existed
back then it sounded so similar to like
an orange county band and it wasn't even
a good version of that i'm sorry
yeah it i i think it's just like i just
like it because it's so
weird and i want like this weird band to
succeed but it definitely is like if
this is the song that saves the universe
it should be a better shot it should be
better yeah and that was it like i like
the premise i liked the setup i think a
a band and a touring band in the star
wars universe it's like
being hunted down and it's like a
padawan and
the hutt
fail sun or whatever that guy was doing
and yeah
i just want the music to be better if
it's going to be like literally a
musical just don't suck yeah because i i
feel like we've or i've complained
before in the past about like everybody
at star wars you only have like three
jobs you're like a mechanic you're a
smuggler you're a storm trooper bounty
hunter or yeah the bounty hunter like
that's it there's like there's there's
only like and and so musician is like a
thing we haven't really explored that
much but
it does make you wonder like well how
did these guys just created this whole
wing of music completely on their own
we've never heard any other music in the
star wars universe that sounds anything
like this it's all like
jazz and new age and like weird space
jazz
we've never heard yeah
there's never been cantina
kids have to exist in the star wars
universe and that's what it was guitar
in star wars history like i think it is
i think it's just literally them being
like this isn't your daddy's music and
it just like sounds different um to us
we're used to it but in the world of
star wars they're very much like well
now i want to cut my hair and dye it
black you know you go okay you guys
might not be ready for that but
but your
yeah some 41 has ancient roots ancient
ancient galactic roots
okay uh let's move on get ready for an
episode that feels like it was inspired
by the last jedi why you like it i swear
featuring more new york than a batman
forever street gang that shows off
what's possible when you go all anime no
breaks with the visuals but still honors
the prequel trilogy by having horrible
stilted dialogue kyber crystal
such beauty
such power
this energy will be a beacon of hope for
the galaxy
bravo allison brie you act you act as
hard as you can
and evil twins
yeah this one was fun um but very very
anime and definitely like uh the first
of uh but maybe most backdoor piloty of
of the episode it's like
wow the adventure begins credits a lot
of them were like hey this is also the
sales presentation of this studio to
disney like rabbit first season green
line yeah we're ready to go
also you can just look allison bree
obviously does voice over work it's not
that she doesn't but like you can really
tell that nph has been doing a lot of
this specific kind of voiceover work for
a while because allison's just like
there's no there's no scenery in the
studio for me to chew but i'm gonna find
some
um she's very much like oh you want me
to be evil i'm going to be like the most
evil person i can be you know
yeah this is a real i don't think we
mentioned it but man they got some heavy
hitters in there for the for the voice
cast for the um
dubbed version uh oh i feel like this is
everybody who like wants to get a foot
in the door to be in a live action star
war or something like that like henry
golding's in there allison bree and ph i
didn't even remember
doing like a harrison ford impression
yeah i didn't even i was watching him i
was watching the japanese version with
subtitles and then i started to see
notes coming from the rest of you and it
was like oh you go alice and bree and i
was like wait there's a little yeah
in japanese for this so i went back and
re-watched them you know to write notes
for this in the in the english stuff so
i've now seen both versions but uh yeah
i didn't even i didn't they didn't
really even advertise they were doing
that that like we're putting a bunch of
celebrities on the yeah like simulu
isn't it like there's an amazing voice i
feel like everyone has at least one
famous person lucy blue we mentioned
yeah yeah
yes
i did not love this one either it just
felt kind of like
it was very colorful and it was very
like you know they this studio uh
they also did that that that anime movie
primary and it's very like neon and
flashing and very like assaulting of the
of the senses and i think that's cool
but i don't i didn't care about this
really at all i thought i liked it i
liked that uh that you they just went so
out there and just kind of i don't want
to say like body horror but just like
very anime with it that like you can
shove a crystal into your body and it
like warps you and warps the lightsaber
and stuff right like yeah she's got that
like suit that like kyber crystal
powered
nano suit or whatever uh yeah i mean
like some cool ideas i don't know this
was the point after two and then three
which i wasn't a fan of i was like oh no
am i like not gonna like that they just
put the great good samurai one first and
then after this i basically have no more
no more complaints like we're we're
we're we're off to the races now yeah i
think that the twins is like my least
favorite out of all of them these two
were definitely the low point for me for
whatever reason and from here on it
really good i liked it yeah i i don't
hate any of them i think and like i said
i think there's things to recommend like
this one it is like it's a it's an
aesthetic and a color palette that
you've never seen in star wars before
which is really cool yeah
all right keep playing
when a village is threatened by raiders
wait didn't we see this one already oh
different village okay when another
village is threatened by raiders it will
take one masterless jedi teaming up with
an anti-master it doesn't suit you that
mask to help two orphans link their
magenas
gina by slicing up imperial scum with a
katana saber and some sweet tactical
high-heeled shoes wait didn't we see a
lady force user in heels already
is that so they always have the high
ground
wedding
crashers uh pause who was the auntie
master i never quite
remembered or figured out who that dude
was
because he's not her master because they
were on the planet of her former master
and
i read it as he
is not a jedi but was just somebody else
that she knew who was like
helping her to stay one step ahead
following order 66 like it was some kind
of friend or family friend or mentor but
she's definitely the one with the force
powers not him
yeah yeah i was too caught up in like
the final fantasy mess of it all i think
totally
earth spirits and um i like that uh uh
women get carried around uh like they
get free piggyback rides everywhere
like okay i don't look i i don't know a
lot about i'm very american and didn't
finish school i went to an art school so
like i don't know a lot about other
cultures but i definitely had a thing
where i was like what do you mean she
like can't touch the ground like she
can't touch like he was very much like
your feet can't get dirty before the
wedding and it's like oh like is is that
a thing or is it like a star wars thing
like i wasn't sure um
i'd also like just i don't know people
are heavy there's like a whole rig like
a whole system of like whatever
i'm not sure but like i'm so heavy the
last anime thing that we watched not
only was the dude carrying the girl
around but she was in a box so at least
this girl gets to breathe fresh air and
see the sun
you know like i feel like this is a
better deal it's not as good as just
walking on your own power but we're
making we're making improvements so i'm
sorry that whole village sucks for them
to be like sacrifice your life for this
old dude you young girl it's not even
explored is what's weird it's like she's
just expected to like well look this is
my duty and it's like it's like 90. like
yeah
this is yeah
i think that again like duh how did they
not think of this already to take of all
the lightsaber variations they've done
to like just make it into more of a
sword like so simple so uh genius i
thought that was the coolest lightsaber
i've seen in a in a long ass time
that shot with the with the heel like
her shoe kind of like coming off because
she's about to do that very like samurai
movie a very cool moment you know and
like i thought uh as good a duel as
you'll see in this
compilation or the movies and it's
really quick like it's not a huge thing
it's all the build up right and the
anticipation and the character work that
they do beforehand that makes it cool
it's not the fact that like she had nine
lightsabers for arms right i mean that's
yeah like a lot of the the sort of like
swashbuckling western movies versus the
samurai movies like that's what you'll
see is like the samurai movies a lot of
the time it's about like the least
amount of movement it's all like
circling and preparation and then like
the one clean strike whereas you know
we're used to that errol flynn like haha
and you're just like
collecting swords over and over again
which is not actually how anybody stage
combat you love to see it yeah uh all
right let's keep going witness is short
that packs so much world building
imagination and likable characters into
20 minutes you won't even care that they
ran out of creativity for the names
greetings my name is ethan as a young
apprentice gets trapped in a temple 47
who wants to steal her custom
lightsabers even though all you have to
do to get one is download the saber pass
after week before you go to the planet
then sign up using the sabre magic
system to book your sabers vacation so
that when you do arrive at the temple
all you need to do is check in get your
saber band log the qr code on saber pass
then report to the light saber store add
300 credits to your my saber account and
get in the 2 hour reserve queue simple
my saber totoro
yeah pause but i love how long that goes
on and if we had more time
i'm one of those people who loves when a
joke goes so far that it gets irritating
and then it gets funny again
i would have loved to have seen us do
that for like two more minutes
i don't know we don't have times we
could have added
one or two one or two more but i was
like you know i think people it reads
have you guys done that at disneyland or
whatever wherever it is guys i haven't
been the last the last time i was at
disneyland
cars land was brand new like i went on
that that cars ride that car's ride is
sick it's really good yeah it's really
fun um but that was like that was the
last that was it's been like eight years
or something yeah yeah i haven't been to
because like when when it was first
happening people were like waiting in
queues like you were waiting for a
beyonce concert and i was like i don't
have and also like it was too much for
my blood at the time um and so now it's
one of those things was like i could get
in and do it but it's also like the rona
so i don't know i think it's still hard
to get into that rise of the resistance
ride right you still have to like make
the reservation on the app and get the
band or whatever i don't know it's like
a whole thing now yeah i mean i remember
i'm old so he used to just be like hey
you show up here get some popcorn you go
on mister
you should be able to line here okay oh
yeah uh wiley coyote says it'll take 30
minutes yeah it's like oh indiana jones
seems crowded you guys want to do jungle
cruise like it was it was it was more of
a that thing it was more for that yeah
but the ninth jedi um awesome uh uh
a lot of um uh cool lifesaver lore
they're kind of like magic mood rings
now they kind of grow and change based
on your uh your affiliation i guess
right uh yeah and yeah they i thought
that was a this was such a cool setup
for uh i didn't mind that this one was
unresolved and they're like well we got
to track down these uh these surviving
jedi and give them their lightsabers so
we can all uh power up together i
thought that was really cool and like
that
it totally it subverted my expectations
because it's like oh well this is the
the world's most obvious trap for these
jedi but it actually turned out to be
the opposite so uh
is margrave that is that a title is that
that guy like who what is a margrave
it's like a it's like a discount okay
right
that's i was like is he like the baron
like the margarita because they're
they're acting like it's a ceremonial
like oh the model oh actually look i
just googled it it is like a like a you
know a feudal title okay awesome i
should have just googled that that's
that
is the holy holy roman empire i wonder
if it's we should watch the uh
check is it margrave in the in the sub
version too
i believe it is yes if i remember
correctly um but yeah it's the medieval
title for a commander assigned to
maintain the defense of the border of
the holy roman empire well there you go
it makes a lot of sense that you like a
religious feudal yeah okay i dig it i
dig it um this was my favorite one i
thought this was super cool uh amazing
amount of world building and
explanations kind of baked in
while you're also having this adventure
and i i really love that like t
t drinking crotchety old bro funny yeah
an actually funny uh droid a real
the opening where it's like the the
asteroid harvesting like that's a
classic star wars movie opening of like
you're in space and like they play with
your sense of scale and it was great
they had everything so much good stuff
in this one it was it was awesome i
would i would watch like the whole
they should let these guys make that
series based on this let's do it
what's his name from heroes i missed him
hey
uh yeah yeah
all right keep playing
from the team that made space dandy
[Music]
i wanna watch this
all right you can't baby's version
was built to sit in a small room and do
math but also given feelings of love
boredom and frustration because star
wars loves to remind us that droids are
slaves
your
name is
toby
no kio
yeah that but this might have been my
tied for least favorite i mean it was
just like
there was just they were throwing a lot
at the wall and going very fast it was
it was like a like a children's like
flip book of of a star wars story and
i i
the animation was cool i did like the
style the change of style and like the
uh the the doctor robot not dr robotnik
who's the good one
bright from mega man right thank you
yeah the opening is just like wait did i
switch over to mega man vision yeah it
seemed like
this time they were actually weirdly
forcing star wars into like a a hole
where it didn't fit which is that style
of anime but for that's just my
preference uh what'd you guys think
i
so i really i liked this one i think it
was cutesy uh again i just always
okay if droids can be jedis
then like that means droids have like
souls or something um they are
definitely people so it's just it it's
just a lot of questions it just thinks
they've opened that can of worms and the
answer is they don't care like i think
they've answered it enough times that
droids are conscious and know what's
happening to them and feel pain and they
don't care because that kid has like a
whole arc where he's like i want to be a
jedi the best jedi in the universe i'm
like ah you stupid little robot that's
never going to happen and then like you
don't have miracles
you don't have midichlorians and then
like his dead master is like oh you've
like knights him and he's like you're a
jedi now and i'm like well wait that
doesn't make any sense hang on you know
that's not part of a jedi's power you
can't you could just proclaim they have
to pass the trials right
there's rules folks uh i i don't know
like at first like the first few minutes
of this i was like boy are we doing
another
is he gonna start singing paramore songs
but uh i don't know this would really
won me over by the end i i really like
the character i like the world i love
the like
guy in darth vader's outfit but he has
like jaws built into his helmet so he
has like darth vader with teeth is like
his design um but yeah i i i really this
one really won me over in a way i did
not expect by the end i thought it was
it was pretty charming oh well i remain
uncharmed uh but that's the animation
it's really cool yeah you don't have to
like them all because it was over so
quickly um all right let's keep going
from the people who also made the psycho
one about the evil twins comes the star
wars vacation of a clint eastwood movie
as a salty old jedi warrior sends his
assistant of a dang mountain to face a
sid while he hangs at a base camp to
make sure he didn't double back uh that
ends with the jedi pretending to be dead
then ganging up in an old man while
they're distracted
this is also supposed to be heroic
elder abuse
yeah i mean i i dug this one it was it
was slow it was
by the other short standards um and i
thought that david harbor was doing was
doing harrison ford i thought that that
was he's very purposefully doing a
harrison ford voice which is confusing
to the point where i'm like
i was like
person ford would not do he was never
never agreed to everest yeah never he's
got his plane he's fine i don't even
imagine like in the plane though
uh the rest of the city of santa monica
and the bank don't think so
i was like imagining him getting that
call from cathy kennedy i wanted to do
what not interesting
[Laughter]
when he's supposed to be putting his
landing gear down and it's like harrison
i think i hit a bird that's the 101. you
can't land there
don't never tell me the odds
listen kathy let this bird down where i
want
uh
yeah i got nothing else to say except um
this was i i thought they did a nice job
uh developing the the the paduan master
relationship you know he wasn't like a
total
jerk like anakin but he you know he was
like a realistic take on like a spunky
young jedi who wanted to prove himself
but he wasn't acting like a complete
idiot and yeah i thought that was nice
it was an it was a nice story uh even
though it's it's grounds that i think
star wars has definitely tried before
what do you guys think
yeah no i again because i do like you
feel like you've seen this before but it
was very much like this felt more like
it was less about the plot and more
about like the morality tale of like you
know you one day are gonna be like the
master like me and then one day you know
the the week become the strong and then
the strong become weak again and like
all of that stuff like if it read more
like a parable to me then like it was
supposed to be about the action and all
that stuff yeah it's just it's
narratively a little weird because it
opens and they're setting up that it's
going to be some sort of like a mystery
like there's something on this planet
that's very powerful but it can't be
that old man and so you're like oh is
this a red herring and then it's like no
it's just the oldest it's still bad so
that's a little odd but once i got past
that and it's like oh it's not actually
a mystery it's just like you said this
kind of simple morality tale about you
know aging and and and you know
accepting your your limitations or
whatever but uh yeah after that i
thought it was pretty good and i think
that the final battle is like neat and
like well done yeah yeah
this was the same studio as the as the
twins one i mean that's uh they had to
get that out of their system like they
used a ball they used up all their pinks
and they were like
the muted browns yeah
cool let's uh is this is this one the
last one
i think there's two more two more all
right let's keep going blast off to the
zootopia system for 20 minutes that will
delight everyone from anime fans to star
wars fans to furries and yes i'm aware
that being a fan of one significantly
raises your chances of being the other
two in this heartwarming saga of a
father having to decide which of his
daughters will inherit the family
lightsaber the tiny tomb with a heart of
gold or the evil human who uses her own
blood as eyeliner do you want pink eye
cause that's the other way to get pink
eye
bunny heist
uh yeah judy hopps um
you know
doing her thing but but even though it
added like a a furry element to it it
was still the kind of star wars
obsession with uh with bloodlines and
dads um
so i can also see this uh uh totally
inspiring another another movie trilogy
and then yeah you really don't see too
many like alien main characters yeah in
star wars it's interesting
um
but yeah i mean i thought it was on one
hand lame that they ended this with a
cliffhanger but on the other hand like
okay i'd watch more of this
uh yeah yeah you sold me you sold me on
a mustache dad and uh and tiny toon
adventures
i definitely think it's funny that like
he did not give a crap about that kid
about love until lop was like no but i
agree with you and he's like oh well now
you're my favorite
oh cool you're the one that's not trying
to throw uh droids in the dark side at
me like
i also like i love all of the little
carrots that love had lab had so many
little symbols that looked like carrots
it was really there was it was pretty
cute but in star wars they're called
kurats
yeah it's a totally it's it's space
carrots it's they're totally different
than earth carrots uh for space rabbits
um yeah i mean like again that's sort of
similar to my feelings than the last one
i i think it was it was
this one the style and the animation and
the
new take on these star wars sort of
aesthetic is what carried me through
more so than the
which which kid is the dad gonna give
the lightsaber to you know like i didn't
get that caught up in the story but i i
still thought it was entertaining enough
and like looked cool and uh yeah we've
never i thought it was interesting that
they like
they explored like the imperial bargain
that they make on the planet of like the
the colonizers of being like well we'll
bring all this increased prosperity um
you know and they kind of get them
indebted and then they kind of turn it
into a into a world yeah because they
have so many planets they don't care if
yours is like filled with whatever the
version of like you know a space oil
tanker hitting your space ocean like
they don't care about that they don't
care about that at all
yeah i mean that it's like uh it comes
back to the thing we haven't sort of
talked about which is uh
some of these find really clever ways to
like interact with their moment in the
universe like we mentioned the the one
with the wedding in the village where
like it it's definitely set in this
moment that we know about where like the
jedi have been sort of wiped out and
like they're kind of on the run or
whatever like
some of them didn't bother they were
just like it's the future i don't know
there's no more jedi whatever
screw you but uh i like the ones that
they sort of figured out a cool moment
that they could like kind of live in and
here's what's happening in this corner
of the galaxy during this famous time
yeah totally
um all right uh the final one that i
will admit i kind of tuned out during i
didn't like this one as much but let's
watch akikiri from still japan but with
a few pieces of african flair comes a
really annoying road trip across the
planet of the tiny mouths in a classic
tale of how when a jedi falls in love
everything turns to
yep even an anime they're creepy sexless
monks who were only allowed to play with
their own lightsabers
literally star wars visions
star i think i just hit my uh i hit my
anime limit um
like i think when you you probably
shouldn't watch all nine of these in a
row and i was just like oh another jedi
sith betrayal
this uh
over wrought love story and i don't know
this one didn't really do anything for
me but i feel like i should watch it
with fresh eyes did did this do anything
for you
it's not one of my favorites like i
thought that the whole thing of like
he's having these visions about this
terrible thing that happens and it's
like a through line throughout this and
then he's helping like the chick that he
loves because
you know her sister her they they
weren't clear like they heard her aunt
or whatever her giant aunt
it becomes a sith and takes over
everything and then oh no the vision
actually happened um yeah it definitely
i don't know
it wasn't my favorite but only because i
just i am so over the idea that like
these jedi
have to not be
human people
um that that set yourself up for failure
there yeah i just think that it's weird
because like that that's such a to me
that feels like such a prequel trilogy
thing and it's one of the things i don't
like about that um that it's anytime i
see that i'm like oh great it's like
another story about how if you actually
have feelings everything is bad but i
mean yeah and it does
maybe it doesn't they don't want to
invite this comparison but i mean it's
true to life that like when you join a
religious border you have to give up
like marriage or whatever at the very
minimum if not sex and anything fun um
it's just not fair like you get to have
look you have to swap your libido for
magic powers that's like a not fair
garden to ask of a five-year-old that's
actually what uh that that happens if
you start if you stop uh pleasuring
yourself you are able to shoot lightning
out of your fingers and uh doing seven
flips off of the couch lennox lewis
knows he used to he was always like i'm
not doing anything until it's time for
me to fight and somehow pepsi had like
this whole extended family explain that
you can oh yeah well yeah
i don't know like i didn't like the
character design i like the world i
enjoyed
checking out this like the wakanda
corner of japan uh i thought that was
cool uh but yeah like i don't know they
kind of had that like polygonal like
early playstation
character design like where it's i don't
know i just i don't like their faces is
this a weird thing to say but um yeah so
that that kind of kept me from like
totally loving this one i did think it
was like a cool i did not guess that
that was going to be
the ending and like i like the sort of
final turnabout it ends the whole the
whole first season on this sort of like
dark weird note which i enjoyed um
but yeah that not not one of my top
favorites mostly because i thought that
the faces of the characters looked ugly
also my complaint about what if so
here you go disney
getting it done yeah you wanna you wanna
end with like a big i thought you wanted
to end with a bang this kind of ended
with like huh that's that's kind of a
downer all right
let's see you next year when they do
this again yeah there's definitely going
to be more of this i'm assuming i don't
think we have confirmation yet but
we should i mean even if it's the same
studios did they make two animatrixes
or just one i think there's just one
animatronics yeah probably well that's a
shame they should just uh anime
everything all anime everything i say
maybe there's new matrix movies maybe
we'll get the next animatrix as well
yeah give me nine studios take on the on
the frasier reboot i want to see i want
to see all those
one whole story that's just about eddie
give it to finally get to meet mariss
[Laughter]
she's a robot
all right let's watch a story
starring
when you all copied off the same kid for
your test i got a bad feeling about this
you have a bad feeling about this i have
a bad feeling about this you've got a
bad feeling about this but i've got a
bad feeling about this and more crystal
talk than a white girl's apartment if
you use the power of the kyber crystal
the crystal is the core of the
lightsaber crystal crystals crystal
crystal crystals crystal crystals
star weed content
okay how is there not a short word luke
skywalker is the principal at a high
school for french maids i figure at
least one anime studio would have had
that idea
yeah that's just my pitch um if i had a
star wars vision it would be
principal skywalker at the at the french
maid academy
it is i will say it is weird that none
of them because schools and like that
kind of like a bunch of padawan's
training together is such a instilled
thing in star wars
and anime like that you would think that
you would do it
star wars anime diagram would be some
kind of teen jedi academy or even teen
sith academy totally both seem
ready made and yeah it's only about like
the volleyball clubs at those two
schools it would be the culinary the
culinary
club
yeah uh good times um well that was fun
uh uh please uh please like and
subscribe if you haven't yet and uh keep
watching for more things of this nature
um this is where we normally play
outtakes but i don't know if we cut
anything
so yeah we did all right well let's see
what what that was
i used to be a sith still am but i used
to
scary poppins just yeah
scott pilgrim versus the hutt
how i met my brother
magina carano
shogun wedding
juro dreams of jedi
hidden figure
astro boy the sorcerer's padawan
oldsmobile
hop and loco
who saved love the rabbit
the killing snoke
vision quest
[Music]
and a may the force be with you
well there you go that's why they're out
takes folks yeah
the killing snoke is good because it's
like one bad day it all takes
tournaments
it's just like the killing joke but for
for too many layers of nuance for for my
attention nobody gets me
uh all right on to the on to the chat um
luis valenzuela asks uh how long do you
think it'll be before we see some of
these vision characters cameo in the
main continuity if ever and if you don't
think like who would you like to see pop
up if they don't get their own thing
just like a little pop in from toby
i want lop
where's ethan where's ethan in the
office
even to the distant future so i don't
think that would there's like long been
no jedi and stuff so i don't think ethan
would work i think a lot feels obvious
yeah
i think that there's no question that in
a mandalorian season you'll see uh the
ronin and the droid with the hat like in
the background
you know in a canteen or something i
don't know if the timelines work but i
think um
uh favre will stick that in there
somewhere i want to see uh look show me
the band all grown up what are they
playing now how is their style change do
they go through like a beatles style
change where it's like they started
doing a lot of drugs and everything got
interesting like where is their uh where
is their pet sounds like
this interesting after being pop punk i
would i'd love to
i i don't know if it's happened
i feel like there's like next year's
world series of pod racing they're gonna
be like the halftime show like that's
the big follow-up yeah yeah yeah that's
get mixed
watto and sobolba gotta get in there mix
things up with this crew
all right this is a good one uh hamid
reza asks what's the best job to have in
the star wars world
are there any good i mean there's only
three jobs bounty hunter jedi or uh
droid
moisture farmers
uh you could be like you could be a you
could be a
spice miner you could be a mechanic uh
mechanic doesn't sound that bad yeah
like right i feel like yeah people who
have like trades kind of jobs in in
villages like they seem like it's it
that's not a bad life like like the
people in mandalorian who are like the
krill farmers before the evil guys show
up like that would be over but the evil
guys always show up evil guys do always
show you gotta find a jedi to keep you
safe when raiders show up i think like a
banker because someone's gotta handle
the credits right
well yeah the trade federation right
yeah if you wanna do the part of the
trade
are you a crude asian stereotype i don't
know if this is gonna work out i just
wanna help people open up bank accounts
it sounds like a really chill life
yeah we all know i would own a junk shop
and have slaves
ethnically that's uh that's that's where
that's where the wato like characters
reside
um
a very swarthy animated character this
might be one for you lon although you do
like you do like animation but jeffrey
love yelverton s i tend to avoid
animation even though i love comics and
enjoy drawing myself why can't people
like me get into animation
and to that i say you just haven't found
your preferred style yet yeah
i love anime it's not a genre it's a
it's a medium and there's so many
different types that you've gotta
there's gotta be something man right
uh i would i would think so i mean like
it's hard for a lot of people especially
in america where we tend to tie
animation a lot of ways to
kids entertainment you know it's like
added the cartoons are for children and
i guess now we've got this one other
category it's like cartoons are for
children or like stoners like there's
also the you know like the adult
animation you know archer group of shows
but i think for a lot of people that's
like the block is you got to find the
stuff that's beyond that that's just you
know for everybody for for a general
audience and it certainly is out there i
mean miyazaki i would say is something
if you don't feel like a lot of other
kinds of anime or animated films have
spoken to you check out my neighbor
totoro or princess monkey okay or
something
yeah those those cross all all over it
away one of those
well good times i'm glad we did this it
was a just a
it's kind of now or never because i i
wonder if people even think about these
in a in a week from now but but it was
fun to watch and fun to write about and
i hope that star wars takes more risks
um and and this proves that they're able
to go in different directions and people
like it because i think we all did let's
do more
um
that brings up next week we'll flip a
coin we'll see what we're gonna do um
either
oh god uh
either something i mean i feel like in
one instance we'll be in pretty good
shape
yeah
okay and then
in the other instance
uh you know we're we're go we're kind of
licensed to do whatever we want
excellent point lon you're you're you're
spot on with both uh and you'll find out
what we uh what we decided next week
here on australia's commentaries thanks
for watching y'all
this episode was brought to you by who
[Music]
you